josh allen your boy blue the bill's
quarterback what's more likely he has
over 350 or under 250 passing in this
game against the chief
he had 122 i know against the chiefs
when they played in week six i know the
chiefs defense is is better to me than
the bills you know the chiefs can play
coverage and do those things
and let their big guys up front stop the
run even though the bills don't run the
ball that much anyways and i don't
expect them to do that here in this in
this week but again under 250 to me is
just i don't see that happening these
are two guys that you know they can get
250 on three throws where you could be
sitting there going oh we're holding
them in check and all of a sudden things
explode in the third quarter and you go
whoa they threw through 250 in the third
quarter so i i think again if i'm gonna
pick either one here and where the
buffalo bills offense has been executing
you've talked about so much how josh
allen's just got an aura of like you're
not gonna beat me and all that i think
they're gonna throw the ball every damn
play this week too for the most part so
i'm gonna own over 350 for him too
okay so then i have a feeling i know the
answer to the next one and i agree with
you it's good i i and part of me is
trying to kind of
speak and wish it into existence
right quarterbacks over three feet like
mike let me ask diggs i was just gonna
say with the quarterback conversation
because he talked about like rogers and
brady and that dynamic there you know
uh i don't know this is just me the
football fan fanboy mahomes allen you
know i love both of them i think we both
do
allen i guess has more pressure on him
right here in this situation like
mahomes doesn't have pressure on him
but i do feel like
mahomes
is slightly threatened by josh allen i
don't know why i just when i hear him
talk about him josh allen challenging
him to the long throw competition and
all those things i when i hear him ask
questions about josh allen i feel like
he doesn't talk as nicely as he does
maybe with other quarterbacks i just
wonder if that's a real element i feel
like josh allen the first time around
he felt the pressure of whoa this is a
prime time game and i need to be as good
as patrick mahomes and he missed some
throws and do all that but i just find
that to be an interesting dynamic of
these two i don't know if you feel the
same way
i think the pressure is squarely on
mahomes you do you're the team this is
the defending championship they're at
home
right josh the bills have already
exceeded
anyone's reasonable expectations could
have been they're on house money and
something about them changed coming out
of the bye week after they lost to the
cardinals in the hail murray they had
the four straight nationally televised
games big platform they were beating the
crap out of everybody now they've had
two more playoff games in isolated
windows they're comfortable with this
moment
i think that there's more pressure on
patrick mahomes and if your perception
is right that he feels a little
threatened by josh allen we could see
a little of that patrick mahomes trying
to do too much that's what i think about
it that's what could make things
problematic for the kansas city chiefs i
i just i that's why i kind of brought it
up i think about it with both of these
quarterbacks where even if like mahomes
got up josh allen might be like i gotta
match him and now he's trying to throw
lasers into triple coverage down the
football field i just something
interesting and when you're used to
being
the man and no i'm the most young
talented guy
i'm the the unicorn
you know and then you start to go wait
somebody else is calling another guy a
unicorn they think he's a mirror mirror
on the wall right it starts that's when
it gets personal when you start to go
wait wait i want to beat this team and
be in the super bowl but i also want to
beat this damn quarterback and show
everybody too that that's just something
that jumps out to me
and something we talked about recently
and there is a very real vibe that is
beginning to make the rounds in the nfl
that if you had to pick between allen
and mahomes for the next 10 years a
surprisingly high people people
are saying alan whispering allen because
we've already been conditioned to think
mahomes is going to be the greatest of
all time when he's done and he very well
may be and i hope he is but but
people are seeing what josh allen has
done this year in his third season and
saying holy crap
the way he throws the way he moves and
you know i've been told there's a
fundamental difference
when you see it live yes with bro with
josh many people when you're in the
building right and you see it happening
live and how he moves and how he can
roll right and throw back to the left on
a laser and there's it's just so much
more impressive live that's what's
causing people number one games who
fought and then that's what's that's
what because people are like oh come on
it's patrick mahomes what are you
talking about every time i turn on the
tv there's patrick mahomes right green
beans with troy palamala
allen can't be no it's it's the gap is
closer than people would think and and
maybe maybe maybe the guy who didn't get
to be the top dog for very long is
already feeling the heat well i mean i
doubt that quite yet but i think he
recognizes talent and he he watches
every game of everything i mean he's
always tweeting doesn't matter what
sporting event so he's i'm sure he's
watched josh allen and gone whoa
this guy's a little threatening to me
he's damn talented and he does a lot of
the damn stuff i do mahomes is cooler
and slicker and things like that
but mike
consistently over the last year i've
heard that from a number of coaches to
what you're saying
you know i didn't realize he was this
good until i turned on the film i just
didn't realize it and then whoa i mean
hey have you ever seen josh allen in
person man you know again he's a much
bigger man than mahomes and he's just as
fast and as quick and his arm is every
bit as strong he might not be as cool
and as slick and do the sidearm stuff
quite as much but i i like you said to
echo your point i think it's more of a
conversation than nfl circles than than
maybe the the you know casual fan
realizes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports